hey guys this is andrew for
trainingcensus.com so let me quickly
introduce myself i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and i've decided a few months ago to do
my youtube channel
because guys i want to show you how
portrayal is actually working all the
different tools and techniques
that we use to make money on the markets
i mean at least those that i use and
that work for me and most importantly
guys i want to show you how to use it
yourself
so if you want to know about all the
stuff and how to
do it yourself at home you guys are in
the right place
so today i want to make an update on
gamestop let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so this is gamestop chart
uh i was actually
uh i did a video yesterday where i was
explaining to you guys why this press
action looks now very bullish for the
volume
uh we broke this trend line and you know
this is
expected uh you can check my videos that
i did like on the 24th of march when i
was saying that this is what we're
looking for and this is what is
happening
so we are in a very beautiful situation
we gonna probably go higher
this week and the week after we are in
the i think third wave of idiot wave
developments and i want to show you guys
a bit more in depth
how to use idiot wave theory applied
to gamestop so let's go in the forest
timeframe
first thing is that we have one
move that is finished for sure this one
so i put it in red
right this wave development one two
three four five this is our first
move up of a larger degree
wave counting so basically waves up
developing five waves
and waves down develop in three waves a
b c zigzag and for the one two three
four five it's usually an impulse or a
diagonal
so we are applying uh this
rules to the chart that we have in here
and we're gonna try
to predict what might happen next
so we have this one two three four five
that is here then we have this abc
so this is actually one wave second wave
and now guys
we are uh developing we are doing the
third wave so it's probably going to be
a very strong one as it's usually the
most important and the strongest one
and we need to find the counting for
this
third wave so i was saying in my
previous videos that i was you know
saying something like this
all right and then i was expecting a
fifth wave to go to 480 before
correcting and then going to 800.
the situation has changed yes so you
need to adapt and actually
right now i see that this first wave is
finished
so i need to use this information
trading is about probabilities guys so
you never show 100 but once you have
some information that you cannot deny
you need to use it here the information
i cannot deny is that we had
a correction so i need to
use this information to make a counting
that is taking it into account
and my counting is actually one two very
small one
but this is a valid counting three four
five so this is our first wave then
you have the second wave that is
developing always guys in
three waves i mean it can be a triangle
but
90 of the time it's gonna be a zigzag or
a flat correction
a b c so once again for those who want
to know more about idiot wave principle
uh just click on the link in the
description of this video and you're
gonna receive
right away guys in the five minutes free
video
a free training where i explain
everything about illiot wave principle
after
i've read the book that is a bit
complicated that's why i did it
like i sum it up to make it very easy
for you guys to understand
basically elliot wave theory consists of
a little game that is to find the wave
development
that is fitting the best and that is
respecting all these rules that i
explained in this video
that you can receive by clicking on this
link in the description
so here we have one
then we're looking for an abc
quite easy and now we are doing a one
two three four five guys
as usual so one
so question is is it one two three four
five
i don't know yet all right so here for
example there is a good question
there is one information you can use to
guess so the information you can use
guys
is every c wave of
zigzag must contain five subways
it is an impulse all right this is one
of the rules that you need to apply
so let's see if actually we find
five waves here so one two
three four five all right so then if
this is one two three four five
this is a one two all right so this is
giving me a nice information
so this is complete the c wave
is finished here and now we're having a
one two that is starting
one two three
four so we're probably gonna have a five
guys
can it be like this it could be like
this all right it could be like this
so let's see what happens uh let's see
what happens
you have different scenarios that are
possible in this situation
so either we do a five and then we
correct more or actually we have already
corrected
okay i see an abc so i think that right
now we're gonna do a one two three four
five
uh another possible scenario is that we
are just doing this
an abc like this that is possible as
well because
once again guys i was telling you that
when you have this kind of strong move
down
usually the momentum shift takes a bit
of time so it's possible that we do a
one-two that is a bit longer that comes
back here
you know a flat correction maybe would
be more appropriate you know so
just don't be surprised if you don't see
a very bullish
um price action starting at the
beginning of the week we can start maybe
only on the 30s of march
to do this new wave development but
whatever we have here guys
whatever we have this is still going to
be a one two
there is no discussion about it so then
we're gonna have a three
four and five then
let me put this one in another color
all right so one two three four five
and this is actually gonna be the third
wave games
this is only a third wave all right
because this is a one
this is a two this is a three
we're going to have the four and the
fifths
so this is my scenario this is the most
likely thing to happen
i think that we're gonna go to 480 again
with a one two three four five then
we're gonna correct once again guys here
we have a zigzag so here we're gonna
have a flat probably you know a flat
is a bit different it's something like
this
zigzag is that that down abc with the c
wave
lower and the flat is a lighter
correction
where a wave a and wave c are actually
going to the same level and usually when
you have a zigzag in second wave here
abc zigzag
usually have a flat here so i expect a
price action development like this and
once again guys look at that
look what i have for you so this is the
open interest that i computed using uh
data that i find on yahoo finance and
this is
showing me guys that there is a very big
big big amount of
call options on the 800 strike and if i
convert
this into notional this is 2.5 billion
usd national
that are sitting at the 800 level this
is what
is actually going to create your gamma
squeeze and i'm going to explain this
very well in another video
so to come back here guys that's why i
am so bullish that's why i believe we're
gonna go to the
800 level and once again if you ask me
why 800
i can answer quickly i just measured the
first wave that's why idiot wave is very
important and i applied to the bottom
of my second wave and this
is the 1.618 the golden number is
actually
the most likely level to be hit and when
i see that the
option concentration at the 800 level is
that high
and i have this 800 given by another
technique
you know it's just it looks like uh
different
methods converge to the same answer
800 is the level we're going to so guys
that's it for me i hope you enjoyed this
video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to show
i'll see you guys